Our class code is the object-oriented
representation of a table in
our database.
The only thing we need to do
is create a class name, and
make it extend from the Base
class we just created.
For conventional purposes,
let's make all of our classes start with
a capital letter with no spaces in
between, also called camo casing.
Inside of this class declaration,
we will add all of the code for
our table and mapper code.
For this project, we will need to
create two classes to correspond with
the two tables we want to create in our
database, restaurant and menu item.
Be sure to write this class
code between your beginning and
ending configuration code.
Inside each of our classes,
we must create a table representation,
we use the special variable, double
underscore table name double underscore.
To let SQLAlchemy know the variable
that we will use to refer to our table.
For conventional purposes,
let's make our table names lowercase,
with underscores for spaces.
Inside our restaurant class, we will
set double underscore tablename double
underscore equal to restaurant,
and inside the MenuItem class we
will set it equal to menu
underscore item, as seen here.